foreign
an unknown number of people have been
killed as violence intensified between
police and protesters with attacks by
criminal gangs
three Haitian policemen were reported
among the Dead the situation appears to
be spiraling into greater violence and
Lawless turmoil
burning barricades and angry crowds
blocked the road to the international
airport in Port-au-Prince for most of
this week Haiti has been disrupted the
capital uh Port-au-Prince has been
disrupted for the most part everybody is
hunkering down uh they're staying home
the streets it's virtually it goes down
uh as there are protests and violent
barricades uh
um against the decision from the
government to raise the uh the price of
oil products in Haiti
that fuel hike seems to have been the
spark that caused simmering discontent
to burst into Flame
Haiti the poorest country in the western
hemisphere is beset by Soaring inflation
criminal gangs that Rob kidnap and rape
with impunity and a largely ineffective
and widely reviled government
the price of basic food items has
increased by 50 percent in the past year
buildings were set Ablaze and food
warehouses looted including one operated
by the Catholic organization karatas
a world food program facility in the
town of gonaid was also looted and
burned wfp officials said what's
important is that we actually lost
enough food to feed
around 100 000 school children for three
months we have four million acuely food
insecure Nations one million of which
are actually quite uh quite vulnerable
and that we prioritize for humanitarian
assistance so when an incident like this
occurs it's impacting the population
it's impacting a very vulnerable
population
the critical situation in Haiti
threatens the stability of the entire
Caribbean says the president of the
neighboring Dominican Republic
s of the multi-dimensional crisis in
this country exceed our individual
capacities and constitute a threat to
stability and security throughout the
region for the Dominican Republic it's a
matter of National Security and to Latin
America as well in the crisis
overflowing the borders of Haiti
A desperate population a government
seemingly paralyzed and a wave of Rage
that continues to grow day by day Rob
Reynolds Al Jazeera